[Music]
[Applause]
well i'd like to share with you guys a
story
this story is about a girl
teenage girl like most of us
and
she wanted to be a nurse
because she felt very pleased
to take care and help people
well one day she was going to travel by
plane
and she had the opportunity to fall in
love with that huge machine that makes
people fly around the world
she was quite confused because
how could she could manage those
passions she had
of taking care of people
and flying at the same time how could
she do it
when she entered in the airplane she saw
a very good looking woman wearing
uniform helping few people to find their
seats with a beautiful smile in her face
and she decided to be like her someday
she wanted to be a flight attendant
to have
this opportunity to fly every day this
to feel this freedom and to be with
different people of different places and
far places too every day
okay that was her dream
well a dream for us can mean a lot of
things
it can be something that happens inside
your head while you're sleeping it can
be also a compliment you you can go to
the person you have a crush on
and say to him or her that oh my god
you're a dream
but it also can be an ambition
and that's what we're talking about
today
an ambition is the strong desire to read
something
and i believe that are a range of
factors that can determine whether or
not we will reach our dreams
some of them are the self-esteem we
receive
the will to succeed we have
the support we receive and the and the
reality
our realistic vision actually
and
to turn this this way of thinking easier
for us
i decided to turn all these factors into
an a math equation and although i'm not
as good as math as i wish but
the the equation was like this
y times e
times w times r
equals x
it's very simple
where
y is your self thing z is the support
you receive
w is your will to succeed r is your
realistic vision and x is your ambition
your dream
interpreting this equation we can see
that every factor is essential
one ob there are two observations that
i'd like to to tell you guys the first
one
is
if you pay attention here you can see
that if there is only one negative
unknown in this equation
it can mess up everything
in your life
for example
if you have
self-esteem
you receive the support
you have will to succeed
you have also an awesome realistic
vision but if you don't have an ambition
in your life
you have no focus it's like you're
running as fast as you can with
everything but you don't know where
you're going
another observation
if you have the support
also the will to succeed
you have an awesome realistic vision and
you also have an ambition but you don't
have
you don't have a self-esteem you you
will hardly reach your dreams because
you won't feel able enough for it and if
you reach it
although it's a victory you won't feel
completely satisfied with yourself
because you'll feel there's a part of
you missing
another point that i'd like to share
with you is that the only external
element that is here in this equation is
the support we receive
this support we receive is directly
related to our society and what it
enforces
so when we are called to do something
something that we never saw
someone like us
apparently like us doing
you won't feel able enough to do it
can you understand that
well
so i'd like to to ask you guys a
question
how much support do you get from this
current society
getting back to our story
our
protagonist
she didn't receive a lot of support from
the society
she decided to search
more about this career that she wanted
to to have
and she she realized some
huge
variations between her
and the
idea of flight attendants according to
this current society
this current society
in her thoughts
couldn't
agree with id with the idea of
a black-skinned woman with curly braided
hair
to be a flight attendant
of course she was sad about it
she couldn't do
be or live the way she wanted to because
of her
appearance she decided to quit about
this dream she had
one day at her school
she was going to an event
and vocational guidance
and there were the special guest in this
vocational guidance was a british guy
while the event was going on he was
paying an attention on her and that was
kind of weird to her
and
when the conversation moment arrived
she told him she was almost given up on
her dream
but she didn't told him why and what was
her dream
at the end of the event he took her hand
look looked her in the eyes and said i
believe in you i believe in your talent
please don't give up on her drink on
your dream
i believe in you
she was shocked of course who wouldn't
be
because that man went from so far to
tell her so simple words and at the same
time and at the same time so intense
word for her
so
based on this support she decided to
take a risk
she decided to make an exam
called
general aircraft knowledge
and this exam
you must take if you want to be a flight
attendant
and she was approved on it
that girl i told you the story was me
two years ago
i am a black skinned girl with curly
braided hair from the suburb of rio in
brazil
and
i'm now believing again in my dream to
become a flight attendant
i couldn't believe in this dream before
because my equation wasn't complete
but
i i know i wouldn't be here believing in
this dream again
if there wasn't for awesome people in my
life supporting me in different ways
like my family my friends
all of you for sure
and
there are
one thing that i'd like to share with
you one more thing
i'd like to say that in this current
society
i am part
of the dreamers club
i dream i make dreams and i love to help
people with their dreams too
so there are two cats two questions that
i'd like to to make for you guys
are you
a dreamer in this current society and
you help people dreams too
or you're just another face in a crowd
that can't dream anymore
henry ford is often reported to have
said that
when everything seems to be against you
remember that the plane takes off
against the wind not with it
i
i don't know how the wind is blowing for
you today
but i know you will solve the equation
in your life that i show you before
and you will and you will reach every
dreams that are inside your heart thank
you